philippe béchade rédacteur en chef de la
bourse au quotidien
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous ce
soir sur arte france pour qu'on
comprenne bien quels aménagements ont
conduit l'irlande l'estonie la hongrie
la pologne a rejoint de l'accord
c'était un petit effort notamment pour
l'irlande parce que je crois que sur la
planète terre c'est quand même le pays
par lequel transite le plus de bénéfices
donc fernando consent à augmenter le
taux de 12 points 5 à 15 la bulgarie
fait aussi un bel effort puisque je vais
c'était 9% dont on passait à castres et
ainsi de suite pour pratiquement
140 pays enfin 136 pour l'instant signé
l'accord il manque encore pakistan kenya
le nigeria et le sri lanka a priori le
pakistan devrait se rallier aux
dernières nouvelles le dernier résistant
sa santé claude le nigeria donc on va
dire que pour l'instant tout le monde
tout le monde a signé sous la pression
américaine notamment par l
bouleversements à venir à partir de 2023
s'est pas réellement un grand
bouleversement ski et bouleversements
c'est que des pays qui n'imposent est
pratiquement pas vont appliquer ce taux
maintenant
si on regarde dans le détail ce qui se
passe dans certains paradis fiscaux je
me demande comment cette taxe va être
appliquée alors
je pense notamment
à singapour
dubaï nous tous sur les bénéfices et 2 0
il ya également les
bahamas
antigua et barbuda
donc je ne sais pas si c'est si ces
paradis fiscaux là
vont réellement appliquées appliquer les
taux voilà alors je tiens d'ailleurs à
signaler c'est quand même assez amusant
comme coïncidence qu'elle sait que
jusqu'à vent juste avant que tout le
monde signe l'accord plusieurs paradis
fiscaux ont été retirés de la liste
noire notamment les seychelles par
exemple et vous y voyez un rapport
flagrant
je pense que c'est pile ont dû donner
des gages de bonne volonté
maintenant
ce toqué ce qu'il est censé rapporter
m'écouter c'est assez facile à mémoriser
15 % à l'échelle
de 140 pays c'est 150 milliards de
recettes fiscales supplémentaires pour
ces pour ces pays
on va dire que l'essentiel de
l'imposition ou illumos système vise
surtout le profit des multinationales
alors réalisant plus de 700 millions de
chiffre d'affaires
là les profits qui sont visés le très
précisément ce sont surtout les 500
milliards des cendres première
multinationale mondiale et qui ont
toutes entre 20 50 70 filiales dans des
paradis fiscaux alors justement ces
multinationales comment est ce qu'elles
peuvent réagir selon vous est-ce qu'il
faut s'attendre à ce qu'elles trouvent
de nouvelles parades
ah ben je crois qu'elles sont même pas
la peine elles sont même pas donné la
peine de trouver des parades je vais
vous citer tout simplement l'exemple
d'amazon
amazon en 2020 c'était 250 milliards de
bénéfices le tout transite par l'irlande
ça ne fait que transiter donc ce n'est
même pas soumis à l'impôt à 12.5 et donc
taux d'imposition 0 alors pour amazon le
diable se niche dans les détails dans
les détails ça ne concerne pas qu amazon
figurez vous que les profits ne sont
taxables qu'au delà d'une marge de 2 10%
autrement dit si amazon parvient à
limiter sa marge en dessous de ce seuil
dans ces bénéfices ne seront pas taxés
alors on se dit quand même bon en france
on se dit quand même avec gourmandise
que il ya matière à taxation mais
figurez-vous que pour une entreprise
comme amazon ci ne possède que des
entrepôts et où les produits le font que
transiter est bien actuellement
une entreprise de cette sorte n'est pas
considéré comme un comme ayant une base
fiscale stable en france donc il
faudrait que ont recalé l'activité
d'amazones en france par exemple pour
pouvoir les taxer et à condition qu'il
fasse plus de 10% de marge et ensuite
ses marges vont de transit et
éventuellement par l'irlande et là elles
ne seront toujours pas taxées ce qu'il
faudrait que l'argent reste en irlande
pour subir la position donc quand vous
regardez l'évolution
des gars femmes donc de toutes ces
multinationales qui vont certainement
quand même payer un petit quelque chose
en plus quand vous regardez leur
évolution boursière depuis des semaines
vous voyez que les investisseurs ne se
aucun moment ne se sont sentis menacés
de voir les profits et les futurs
dividendes
en douter très sérieusement par ce
projet de taxation mondiale un tout
dernier mot philippe béchade nous sommes
en plein scandale des pandora paper
c'est ce qu'on peut voir un lien avec
cette décision d'une taxe mondiale qui
finalement fait consensus alors qu'il
était jusque là on l'a rappelé rejetée
par plusieurs pays
oui à la map et perth pandora paper
ce projet de taxation
il ya des gens qui travaillent dessus
depuis dix ans
on sait que l'équipe autour de bruno le
maire planches là-dessus également
depuis quatre ans donc on va dire que
ça vient ça vient de loin mais c'est
vrai que ces grosses affaires très
médiatisées
peut-être pas suffisamment d'ailleurs
mais bon panama peppers et il ya des
derniers en date
ça démontre qu'il ya effectivement des
sommes colossales je vous parlais tout à
l'heure des 500 milliards de profits
dégâts femmes là on est sur un ordre qui
se chiffrent en dix mille milliards vous
voyez donc appliquer effectivement 15 %
de taxes sur sur des sommes comme ça et
plus aucun pays au monde n'est en
déficit le problème c'est que cet argent
là ne ressortira pas et tant qu'il ne
circule pas et bien il ne sera pas taxée
merci beaucoup pour votre à éclairage ce
soir philippe béchade rappelle que vous
êtes rédacteur en chef en chef de la
bourse au quotidien